US intelligence officials say Russia is
once again interfering in the
presidential election in a classified
briefing last week lawmakers were told
Russia is helping president Trump's
reelection campaign and senator Bernie
Sanders acknowledged he was briefed last
month about Russian efforts to boost his
candidacy Sanders condemned Russia on
Friday calling Russian President
Vladimir Putin a thug and telling him to
stay out of US politics meanwhile at a
campaign rally in Las Vegas
president Trump minimized the
intelligence findings and instead
pointed the finger at Democrats they
said today that Putin wants to be sure
that Trump gets elected here we go here
we go again Sanders also suggested the
revelations were politically motivated
he is leading in the polls ahead of
today's Nevada caucuses the US
Intelligence Committee has community has
previously concluded that Russia
interfered on president Trump's behalf
in the 2016 election for more on that
we're joined by CBS News justice and
homeland security correspondent Jeff
Pegues who also authored the book
compromise how Russia compromised
America's democracy Jeff is in our
Washington bureau this morning mr. pjs
good morning what what are the main
goals of the Russians now is it bigger
than favoring one specific candidates
well good morning Jeff it is bigger than
one specific candidate and that's why
this is such an important topic for
people who are either Democrats or
Republicans this is take two of the
Russian influence campaign obviously
they were not deterred in 2016 and so
what we're hearing is that US
intelligence officials have breathed
both members of Congress and the White
House and what we're hearing that is
coming out of these hearings is is
something similar to what we heard
happened in 2016 and so for law
enforcement officials it's important
that they get the message out and that's
what we've been seeing over the last
several weeks really over the last
couple of years the question is have
they done enough to deter the Russians
from trying to influence the
and process more the good thing in this
case is that US intelligence officials
are seeing these signs early in 2016
that didn't happen in fact and that's
one of the reasons why I wrote the book
in 2016 they were law enforcement and
intelligence officials who during the
summer before the election in November
started noticing this and really getting
alarmed by it so in this case US
intelligence and law enforcement
officials are are hip to what the
Russians are doing relatively early and
that is perhaps a good sign Jeff is
there any indication as to how these
tactics tactics rather have evolved well
they seem to be the same Michelle and
that's the thing the Russians are trying
to sow as much chaos discord as possible
by especially when it comes to social
media influencing what you see in your
social media with fake accounts now
social media companies have tried to
push back on that over the last couple
of years they've tried to take down some
of these fake accounts but it is an
impossible job to take down all of them
and that's something that we learned
when social media companies were also
fighting Isis fake personas online and
so it is a major task to stop these
influence campaigns especially when you
live in a country with with cell phones
everybody has cell phones in this
country and that's why we have become
such targets for foreign adversaries
intent on influencing what we see what
we hear what we think which in my
opinion and this is something that I
talk about in the book is something can
that can ultimately lead to how you vote
Jeff Pigasus a lot of information in
there we'll continue to watch it is just
the beginning thank you